tenet has a lot to offer moviegoers
whether it's your first christopher
nolan film or your 11th it's big
bold but it's also flawed there's a lot
to recommend in this ambitious movie but
even its biggest fans would admit
there's a few things that could be done
better
like many filmmakers christopher nolan
seems to have a list of favorite actors
to fall back on when starting
pre-production on a new project
we can only hope robert pattinson gets
added to nolan's first look list
because he rules in this movie you want
to crash a plane
we're not from the air i'm so dramatic
pattinson's character
neil has a particularly difficult part
to play in this film as he has a
lifelong friendship with john david
washington's protagonist that the
protagonist
doesn't even know about until the end
pattinson maintains that facade with
ease and artistry but throws in little
bits of emotion here and there to
portray neil's inner conflict
as he tries to repress his natural
inclination to be the protagonist's
friend in their more casual
conversations
it all helps the audience to understand
that relationship in his totality later
on
he's a little goofy and fun too
sometimes appearing in scenes with a
loose tie and rumpled appearance when he
doesn't need to be putting on airs for
anybody
or aiming for humor and charmingly
missing the mark his performance adds a
much appreciated spark to the film
[ __ ] nolan's tendency to write
emotionally sterile characters for
twisting narratives that use
people-like pieces in a sophisticated
game it's been mentioned many times
before but christopher nolan's fondness
for big
booming scores a tradition tenant lives
up to admirably
has a tendency to get in the way of
something very important to just about
every movie
specifically dialogue
do you understand the words that are
coming out of my mouth
this has been an issue that's been noted
in several nolan movies but it's
especially frustrating in tennis which
can come off as confusing even when the
dialogue is crystal clear
to keep track of a movie's story goals
and character motivations the audience
generally needs to hear what people on
screen are actually
saying not just get the gist in that
respect the audio mixing intent leaves
something to be desired
especially given that nolan opted to
have characters wear masks in multiple
scenes
while delivering what would seem to be
extremely important lines of dialogue
did you follow any of that it's extra
frustrating that the difficult to
discern dialogue
is reportedly intentional this is not
the product of a subpar
sound design team considering that nolan
has consistently insisted that tenet
should be seen as a theatrical
experience
it's hard not to appreciate his interest
in dialing that experience to the
maximum level with intense bass
and all-encompassing surround sound very
few homes can recreate but when all of
that noise keeps you from hearing the
movie it robs the film of substance
and leaves a sense of hollow spectacle
fortunately the issue is something that
can be easily fixed for the eventual
home release
if nolan and warner brothers choose to
anyway here's hoping the filmmaker and
his mixing team take the hint that's
been swirling around the internet since
tennant first hit theaters do you
understand the words that are coming out
of my mouth
don't nobody understand the words that
are coming out of your mouth man
tenet has a pretty unambiguously happy
ending which might surprise long-time
fans of the director who've spent
countless hours discussing the
philosophical and moral ambiguities of
some of his other works
that's a big accomplishment for a movie
so interested in the complexities of
time
and manipulation of time to change the
outcomes of events
in a world where many characters good
and bad have access to temporal reset
buttons
nolan made the hero's actions matter
building toward a victory that seems
like
it will stick that's partly accomplished
by his selectively doling out
information about the plot and how it
works
the time travel mechanics matter when
they need to but the movie is willing to
shrug its shoulders at a lot of the
nitty-gritty elements to avoid making an
already confusing movie into something
hopelessly headspan
it's a brilliantly calculated precise
controlled amazing story
that's also completely out of control
just as the protagonist has to learn to
feel instead of think his way through
the challenges faced in tennant
nolan seemed to approach the tenant's
screenplay in a similar way
encouraging viewers to feel their way
through a complicated story without
bogging things down with excessive
details for the most part
and try to understand it
feel it elizabeth debicky as cat andre
sater's wife does a magnificent job in
her role
the trouble is that the role is well
written a bit then
her entire motivation is boiled down to
wife and mother
and that doesn't really cut it for
giving women their do in cinema anymore
on top of that she's a battered wife too
which is a trope that's viewed less
favorably than ever in the post me too
landscape this isn't a fundamental flaw
necessarily it's neither the first nor
the last time we'll see this old
character type on screen
and to nolan's credit cat's journey
through the film isn't just about being
saved by a man
and she isn't a reward for the
protagonist is a romantic interest at
the end either
instead she conquers her oppressor
through the power of her own will
and finally grasps control of her own
life that's good
great even but it's all predicated on
doing it for her child
and her motivation as a mother finally
transcending her fear as an emotionally
battered and physically abused wife
it's not necessarily a harmful
stereotype it's just
boring and well trodden territory in a
movie that has way bigger ideas going on
elsewhere
one of the reasons audiences go to
christopher nolan movies is to see
extremely cool visual effects and boy
does tenet ever deliver
the filmmakers set that bar extremely
high with blockbusters like inception
and interstellar
and this film clears that bar even if
you happen to watch the movie on mute
for some reason
it's a worthwhile experience purely on a
visual level the fight choreography in
particular is a stroke of genius because
no amount of editing can give you the
viscerally impactful look these scenes
achieve without tons of training
for the sequence in the vault during
which the protagonist fights himself
john david washington and his stunned
doubles would have to practice those
sequences
forward and backward which requires
extraordinary discipline in planning and
movement
and again they did it twice from
opposite perspectives there's no other
way to describe that but to just say
whoa you can also tell that most of the
movie utilizes
chiefly practical stunts even the ones
that show an entire airplane ramming
through a parking lot
a lot of the car stunts require multiple
takes from multiple angles
and car stunts are some of the most
expensive to execute in the industry
warner brothers needed to pony up
another blank check for nolan with
tenants and once again
he produced amazing results it's kind of
a quibble but aaron taylor johnson's
ives is a very entertaining character
that clearly had a deep backstory that
the audience never gets to see
that oversight becomes more of a problem
when the movie ends with ives and
possession of the most important thing
in the whole story the algorithm
nolan needed to leave a little more time
for this character to be explored giving
the eventual significance to the plot
and especially its conclusion
ives enters the story halfway through
and quickly displays
a level of practical knowledge about
inversion and combat utilizing it that
quite possibly surpasses nils
he is commander of what is obviously a
very experienced combat team that
specializes in temporal situations
time seals basically that kind of
training doesn't just appear in a
person's brain and muscle memory one
sunday afternoon
this too is likely the kind of training
the future protagonist will eventually
help create
but even an acknowledgment that that's
the case from ives would have been
prudent for helping the audience
understand and relate to this character
without more to go on the movie ends
with this whole deal being a big
compelling mystery john david washington
might be the protagonist
but we wouldn't mind a closer look at
this other important hero's journey
either
the ultimate moral tenet wants to in
part is pretty wholesome and simple the
protagonist
is the protagonist in really literal
terms and his motivation is not all that
separated from the hero
in your typical role-playing game he
grows into his own self-confidence
and acts with deep empathy to protect
others and when he falls short he trusts
his friends to help him even when he
can't anticipate what he'll need or when
friendship trust love and killing god
turns out tenant is just like final
fantasy so you you want me to let
someone else follow you into your
fantasy
jokes aside the emotional truth
underlying the film is reflected most
obviously in the little catch phrase
that begins popping up halfway through
ignorance is their strength it sounds a
little negative at first but the point
is a profound one the characters keeping
information from one another
proves the strength of their trust in
and love for each other
tenant's audio mixing definitely makes
it more challenging to understand what's
already a complicated story but this
problem is compounded by the way the
actors delivered dialogue throughout the
first half of the movie
it feels rushed though it doesn't really
need to be and there is a distinctly
stilted feel to the cast's delivery at
first
sometimes characters even talk over each
other for no apparent reason
there's no established need to hurry all
that much at any point in the first half
of the movie there's no benefit to
having characters rattle off breathless
run-on sentences containing extremely
complicated and nuanced theories of time
and relativity to make them sound
intelligent
unfortunately that happens several times
until the movie seems to catch its
breath and recoup
after cat is wounded and the action
returns to oslo
what makes this all particularly
upsetting is the fact that the first
half includes
very very critical exposition of how
aspects of time travel works in the
movie
it's information that pays off much
later and even more importantly
it underscores how some people think
inversion works which isn't necessarily
entirely correct
or how they're even lying to others
about how it works you have to
understand what the original lie was
in order to truly benefit from seeing
the truth revealed tenet is smart but
there are times when it needs to slow
down
and make it just a little easier for the
audience to absorb
everything it's seeing and hearing the
tenant score ends up being a bit of a
double-edged sword at the moment when it
surges up and over the dialogue but on
its own
it's excellent mini a meme has been made
riffing on nolan's love for big
subwoofer busting film scores
and that tendency is definitely heard
here but a new fresh flourish has been
added by the current hottest commodity
in the film composer market
ludwig gorensen the oscar-winning
composer of black panther and more
recently the mandalorian was tapped to
handle those duties for tenet and he put
extra effort into the end result by
including his own kind of musical
wordplay it might take an extra
screening or two to pick them out but at
various points in the story
the music is played and then immediately
inverted either by playing notes in
reverse progression to mirror the
previous phrase
or actually reversing the recording it
makes for a fascinating and sometimes
disorienting listening experience
but one that tracks with the logic of
the movie in some instances
it even helps you understand what's
going on well i've seen too much
well we'll try and keep up christopher
nolan's plots are historically
convoluted
but if you're paying attention you can
usually piece it together
and tenet is no exception in fact the
film makes several
fairly obvious efforts to explain itself
in order to prevent the audience
and the protagonist from getting too
lost along the way maybe even a little
bit
too obvious actually the protagonist
asks a lot of very direct questions that
make sense
but they can also feel like a
screenwriter's checkpoint for the
audience
as if to say you keeping up great let's
move on this feels the most pointed at
the very end
with neil and the protagonist's final
exchange half of it is a lovely
emotional beat as the protagonist
realizes how important neil
is to him and vice versa but it also
serves as a last minute checklist of
answers to explain exactly what just
happened
and it feels a little clinical in the
long run it's better to do that than to
err on the side of not explaining
anything at all
but it just feels a little unbalanced
tonally speaking
of course this flaw like all of
tennant's flaws doesn't come anywhere
close to sinking the film as a great
experience overall
they're just the kind of mistakes that
will naturally occur in any filmmaking
process
even if you're christopher nolan check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite movies and tv shows are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one